it's Barcelona's number one tourist draw
la sagrada familia antoni gaudí's still
uncompleted basilica with its innovative
design and construction has a way of
amazing and enchanting nearly every
visitor it's amazing I don't know how to
describe it but it was kind of my dream
to come here hobby of mine city for
eight hours and I thought this was
something that I ought to see I'm is a
busman's in his Oregon
you could look up Olivia I think it's
wonderful to have a square across from
the church a place of quiet before you
enter the building more than 3 million
visitors come to Sagrada Familia each
year that can leave little room for
locals who like to visit the square
across the street also people who live
in the district here love this place
anyway squares are part of the Spanish
culture people sit here in the shade
they gossip about the neighbors and
discuss the politics Spain without the
so-called Plaza is unimaginable for
these two men the Placer Sagrada Familia
is part of their lives Fernando lastra
and Francisco behera have lived here
with their families for 40 years this is
their home where they raise their
children but the increasing tourist
activity is getting on their nerves na
na review we used to have a quiet
neighborhood here where you could go for
a nice relaxed stroll and now there's
this ruckus momento de guerre intact
Alina thought about it's become an
amusement park with all the trappings
tourist buses hustlers pickpockets so uh
toritos que vienen car turistas ese
traje trono for years these men and the
local neighborhood association have been
fighting to preserve the original
character of the area bakeries and fish
shops have had to make way for
businesses catering to tourists aquilo
que is from one up would be more than
what we have here is a real monoculture
of souvenir sharks and fast food
restaurants they have a lot of economic
power and stuff that's why the rents for
businesses have gone up so much less
demand that has a negative effect on the
diversity of the neighborhood why not
esis time for nintendo and this is andy
no valio one of the last food markets
that's been able to stand up to
competition from tourist business is a
little way off from the church it's
mostly local residents who shop here and
the market rarely sees tourists as
customers
button a my yang they usually come in
groups and don't have any time runs only
the ones traveling alone sometimes stop
in and look around but they don't buy a
lot fatal me then the city government is
trying to halt the disappearance of
small food markets they've closed down a
few souvenir shops especially those that
had opened by outmaneuvering the
authorities
lagasse las tiendas is a venir the shops
open under false pretenses they claim to
sell something else but gradually they
transform into souvenir shops so we have
to be especially vigilant and take
immediate action to make sure this
doesn't happen emd rose espinoza paz con
oh but Francisco behera Fernando lastra
and their neighbors have no faith in the
urban planners they've known for some
time that entire apartment blocks around
plaza Sagrada Familia are slated to be
torn down the church and the hordes of
tourists are set to grow and the
longtime locals have to make way I guess
me Toto la vida we've spent our whole
lives here this is our neighborhood our
memories everything will they be able to
provide housing for us nearby under the
same conditions as here though that's
hardly everything we've built up over 40
60 70 years will lose a little bit the
urban planners dream is the local
residents nightmare but the millions of
visitors are unlikely to notice any of
that they might notice that the area
around la Sagrada Familia reflects less
and less the Catalan way of life a charm
that will be increasingly lost
you